all right we're gonna be all giddy
tomorrow night because
it is one of the off-season events that
we wait for and it's finally here
usually it happens before the draft guys
it's happening now on thursday may 7.
and usually when it happens you've got
basketball playoffs hockey playoffs
baseball season has just started and the
schedule release still dominates the
conversation well now it's all we got
the nfl's 256 game regular season
schedule to be released tomorrow night
at 8pm eastern
and
uh look
uh peter let me start with you
we expect a normal looking schedule but
i also expect that there will be plenty
of clues that people will immediately
start
scouring the schedule to try to find as
to what the nfl's contingency plans may
be
mike i would uh i would look for those
clues um and i would look for in the
first two or four or maybe both weeks of
the season look for those weeks to be
portable in other words look for those
weeks to be able to easily fit
on the end of the current schedule
so that perhaps
week three or week five if the season
has to be delayed would be the nfl's
first
week of the season
and then either two or four weeks could
get simply and easily tacked on to the
end of the season
so that the last four weeks of the
season would actually be the last four
weekends in january and the playoffs
would begin february 6th now i don't
know that's going to happen no one knows
it's going to happen but for the nfl the
one thing they don't want to do
they know that they're going to have an
imperfect season
if and when they play they know they
might only be able to play x games this
year and they also know
and no one will say it inside the league
yet that it's possible possible that not
every team will play eight home and
eight away
um so i think what the nfl is going to
try to do with this schedule
is make it the most malleable it can
so that
it will be possible to pick up the
schedule with week one let's say being
in the week five schedule that they
delivered to america on thursday night
well is there any inklings or clues you
know from have you either one of you
heard are we gonna hear any contingency
plans when they do release the the
schedule tomorrow night i mean are we
gonna hear anything about i don't think
so chris
no you don't think you're gonna hear
anything like that the nfl
i think the nfl is simply gonna say that
hey look here's our plan right now and
this could change but as of right now
this is our plan
and we intend to go forward as long as
there are no uh you know
no detours no roadblocks coming forward
but i think we all know that there are
some roadblocks coming forward right i
mean that's where i want to ask you guys
do you
are you curious to why were
why even have the schedule release yet
why well let's let's not wait let's
let's try to let things flush out a
little bit right i mean to me that is
the biggest question right now is oh
let's have a schedule release and we're
not really sure what the schedule will
be for life here in america and then
we'll you know reorganize from there i
mean i understand it i understand you
know it's kind of the tradition of the
nfl to do it this time of the year but
it's just a different year and it just
to me seems right right now there's just
there has to be 10 different contingency
plans so what peter said maybe we got to
cut games out what do we do about teams
in states that might not be open for
business or might have different rules
and laws and you can't stay and practice
in those states or have large gatherings
i mean that's where i'm just uh you know
not just confused as far as why we're
doing it quite yet
well and there's a balance that has to
be struck between creating a sense of
normal but also having the contingency
plans in their pockets and they do but
from the nfl's perspective the idea is
project confidence project a sense that
they are resolute that they are
determined that they have their plan and
if the plan has to change later so be it
but for now here's our plan 256 regular
season games with the chiefs hosting
someone on thursday september 10 to get
the season started and it all goes from
there and if they have to change it they
will now remember this remember this
there continues to be whether it's
justified or not there continues to be a
sense of optimism
within the league that by the time we
get to september the world will be
dramatically different than it is today
the testing will be much more prevalent
easily available easy to do a quick swab
of the mouth a prick of the finger for
diagnostic testing for antibody testing
the tests will be everywhere and by then
the thinking is that our collective
mindset will be
you know who you are if you need to stay
home you know who you are if you can go
out in public if you can go to a game
especially if they have the antibodies
and we know by then more about what it
means to have the antibodies which are
evidence that the virus is already
processed through your body so i i think
that that this schedule
is the reflection of that confidence
peter that the league has
that by september
things will be much different than they
are now even if no one is really coming
out and saying it that way
no question about it mike and it could
well be that they'll play the 256 games
exactly in the order that the nfl says
that they'll play it but
this is different
right
than
free agency or the draft free agency in
the draft
basically are not
something that
uh is it's a scheduled event but it
doesn't mean that you have to do
anything right now okay you know you're
you're going to change teams if you're a
free agent but you don't necessarily
have to go to that team yet you're going
to get drafted by a team in the draft
but you don't necessarily have to go
there yet with the release of the
schedule one of the reasons the nfl
releases the schedule is
it gives a little bit of juice to all 32
teams
and quite honestly to a lot of people in
the travel industry
for people scheduling their trips for
the season you know buying tickets you
know the group of college roommates you
know who
who went to
ohio state and they meet in cleveland
every year to go to a browns game or
something like that well
i doubt sincerely that there are going
to be many or any
uh schedules made
uh tonight you know or plans made for
big junkets uh anywhere in the united
states coming this fall now who knows
maybe they will but
i just don't really see the urgency to
release the schedule right now i don't
really think that there's any good
reason for it right because it could
very well be that on july 20th they're
going to say okay
we now know that team x is not going to
play at home cannot play at home until
thanksgiving so team x is now moving to
city y
and you know so
all i all i can say is you know to me
there is no good reason to do the
schedule now it's not the biggest thing
in the world but i just think the nfl is
going to be
is going to have to get out a big eraser
there's a good chance in two months and
i just don't really understand why it's
happening now other than the fact well
we do this every year let's project
confidence that we're going to play the
season
yeah i mean i'm with you that's why i
raised the question there at the you
know at the start of the segment it just
to me it just seems a little
presumptuous at this point and it does
seem that you know
right now it seems realistic to think
that 16 games are not going to happen in
the normal fashion that we know it to be
and the schedule is not going to be
completely normal now listen does it add
juice and excitement am i excited yeah
i'm excited i'm starving for anything i
mean i'll take any sort of live action
live tv they can get to us right now
here's the other thing i think that's
interesting you know if you're a team
right let's just say you're the new
england patriots
and you're scheduled all of a sudden
it's week one the schedule came out
you're going to kansas city all of a
sudden you're bill belichick and you
spend two
two months on preparing for kansas city
and all this and then things change i
mean i know these aren't like world
ending problems but there could be a lot
of angry coaches who go man i wasted a
lot of time because you guys had the
schedule release and we kind of got
ready with game plans and maybe to start
a training camp or whatever it may be to
prepare for that game and even maybe the
second game because that's what teams do
too they'll prepare for game one and a
little bit of game two to where that's
you know a moot point i know that's not
like world changing or anything like
that but that certainly is gonna
frustrate some coaches and some players
along the way if this does happen
well and chris you're touching on
something that i want peter to elaborate
on the idea that there necessarily will
be some competitive imbalances here you
wrote about it monday it is unavoidable
i mean what if the season begins with
stadiums empty in some states and then
later in the year the stadiums are open
and if you're the 49ers and you went to
seattle in september and there were no
fans there so it was a hell of a lot
easier to play the seahawks in their own
stadium but then the rams go in december
and the stadium's full and they're
registering earthquakes on the local
richter scale because of how loud it is
there you've got a competitive imbalance
in that nfc west it feels like
somebody's going to get screwed and
somebody's going to get an unfair
benefit
once they start as you said taking the
eraser out or just by virtue of when
stadiums are allowed to accommodate fans
you know mike i quoted a a top uh team
executive in my column on monday
and he said basically at some point
we're gonna have to start accepting the
fact that this is going to be a year
where there are going to be some
inequalities
just like the one you just mentioned
and i'll with all due respect to that
scenario with the seattle seahawks
wow oh no no i know but no i agree with
you but it's gonna happen hey
but but some team is gonna say that i
understand mike some team is gonna say
that and i guarantee you when they say
it i'm going to start playing the
violins and i'm going to say nut up baby
because you have to understand that this
year
this year absolutely is going to be
different from any other year
and because it's different from any
other year
who really cares if some team has to
play in seattle with a crowd and some
team got the benefit of not playing and
mike i'll tell you the big deal in my
opinion the big deal
is going to be
if some team and i look we can all
speculate whatever we want about this
but i would bet that some
team might play
an imbalanced number of home and road
games
and if that happens now that's a real
you know competitive imbalance but again
if somebody does
to me
a coach
or a gm or an owner who has to play an
imbalanced number of home and road games
would
would curry a lot of favor not just
within the league but in the united
states who say hey listen we're lucky to
be playing football
yeah that's right you know so i'm not
gonna whine about having six home games
in ten road games
yeah yeah i right you're right and man i
almost lost it with your little phrase
there buck up bart is what i would like
i like what you said there you're funny
uh usually usually sims is the one i
have to worry about for two hours peter
not you
yes you got to worry about peter too
he's got a big mouth and it's not a
great filter just like me so it's
perfect but you know i mean i i do look
at it and go if the season gets
shortened you know first off i agree
with a lot what peter said it's going to
look very insensitive if teams are
sitting there you know people are going
dying dealing with world worldly issues
health issues money issues and teams
complaining oh i only had four home
games and this team had five home games
that's not fair you know that won't look
good to peter's point you're right and
it just seems like hey you know 1982
1987 strike seasons they were very weird
and different you know and it's just
going to be about the teams that prepare
the best to deal with what's about to
face them and who can handle it the best
and limit the distractions and not be
worried about oh where we're playing a
game and this team got to play home and
we did it and whatever else it may be
uh so it's gonna be an imperfect year
you're i have no doubt about that i just
don't see how it could be a perfect 16
game schedule and everything as of right
now unless there's just a dramatic shift
and and cobit 19 and how it's uh kind of
you know being dealt with by the world
right now
and chris i'm glad you mentioned 1982
and 1987 because both seasons were
impacted by strikes washington won the
championship both years and there's no
asterisk applied right to their lombardi
trophies in 82 for anyone out there who
doesn't remember or wasn't alive there
ended up being only nine games in the
season because of the strike and each
conference had an eight team tournament
to determine who got to the super bowl
nobody ever says that takes away from
what washington accomplished that year
87 there was a week that was lost to the
strike then three weeks of replacement
games where some teams had the foresight
to have a replacement team that was
worth a crap and some teams just didn't
care and you know what at the end of the
day that kept good teams out of the
postseason and it let teams that weren't
worthy in and washington won the super
bowl and nobody said jack's squad about
it then and nobody says anything about
it now so when we talk about this
potential for imbalance inequity more
road games than home games empty
stadiums here full stadiums there
when it's time for someone to raise that
silver trophy and hopefully that
eventually happens
they will join the pantheon of super
bowl champions and that will be that and
no one will say we need to scratch an
asterisk into that trophy peter
yeah mike you know i i think you
couldn't have said it any better i agree
totally and i just i i just want to make
one other point about
sort of
you know the the league as a whole this
year with this entire issue okay so
roger goodell basically in this year so
far
has had probably the best
collective year
of his commissionership
you know he gets a new cba that extends
the
um you know the labor agreement for
another decade
uh he he stands firm for free agency and
the draft at a time when there's nothing
going on in america and everybody says
thank you nfl
so he's really this is as good a
five-month run
as roger goodell has had i think as the
commissioner of the nfl
but i think now
he's got to look at this in a different
way
okay
whereas he's got to be very steadfast
the train's going to run on time we are
running the draft i think now
he has got to look at the nfl season
and he can't say
everyone will have access to their
facilities everyone will play eight home
games and eight road games or else we're
not playing
you're not going to be able to do that
probably or you're not going to have a
season so i think roger goodell has sort
of got to do what good nhl teams do on
the power play they change on the fly
and so
i think and i think he will do that he's
smart enough to realize that
if the county commissioner in santa
clara county california
issues an edict that says and he's and
he has basically said i don't see any
games in our county until thanksgiving
now who knows that can change but if
that happens
they just got to figure it out they
can't stop the nfl season because one
team is not going to be quote treated
fairly and i think the nfl is going to
come to that realization
peter something you said there reminded
me of a line from a great american rock
and roll song if the train's on time you
can get to work by nine taking care of
business that's what the nfl is trying
to do that's what we're trying to do
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports